New York just experienced the largest
population loss out of any state within
the u.s. in 2018 in terms of raw numbers
in fact over the past nine years 1
million people have left New York City
and the tri-state area today almost 300
people are leaving this area every
single day but for centuries New York
has been one of the most sought-after
cities within the US and given its wide
range of career opportunities bustling
urban life and plethora of historic
landmarks it's no wonder why so many
people want to move to the city however
Newark City has many prominent cons as
well including high taxes a high cost of
living and cramped living spaces but
these cons haven't stopped people from
moving here in the past so what's
different now well starting off many
industries that are mobile have left New
York specifically a tech industry now
don't get me wrong here New York is -
one of the biggest tech cities in the US
but today it is no longer the only tech
city in the u.s. tech companies have
established branches across the u.s.
especially in fast-growing states like
Texas and Florida as a result many
people who wanted to work in these huge
tech firms just stay in their home state
really the only industry that is still
sort of exclusive to New York is Wall
Street but even that is diversifying
especially with the help of technology
which has introduced apps like Robin
Hood into the market overall the vast
range of career opportunities that New
York ones offered is simply no longer
unique to New York at the same time
people who have moved there over the
past few decades which are mostly
Millennials are starting to get married
and have kids and New York isn't the
most friendly place to raise a family
these Millennials were excited to move
there at first as they didn't have many
responsibilities and thus not as many
expenses however settling down
introduces a new array of expenses which
has pushed many Millennials to opt for a
cheaper place this is nothing new every
generation we see the aging generation
who are star solid Dom moved out of the
urban cores who are then replaced by the
new young
generation but the issue with this era
is that as Millennials move out the
newer generations don't want to move in
as they can find the same career
opportunities without moving to New York
moreover over the past few years
New York has seen and rotten jobs due to
a growing anti-capitalist sentiment
within the state just last year as
Amazon was trying to open a second
headquarters with the New York
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez are represented
from New York led a movement to stop
Amazon from building a second HQ she was
leading a movement to demand better
working conditions and higher wages from
Amazon and if this was the only place
with the qualified population of talent
and visuals Amazon may have bent but
given the rise of several other states
with not nearly as aggressive business
policies Amazon has seen no reason to
pursue new york given the opposition
this now only directly lost 10,000 jobs
but probably also on sells many other
businesses with the plasterer one day
moved to New York anyways moving on no
only is New York not attracting a new
population into the state but they're
also making it unpleasant for people who
are already living there it's no secret
that New Yorkers are heavily dependent
on the city's infrastructure for daily
life as driving within the city's
traffic is even more of a nightmare
and unfortunately New York City subways
and bus services have entered the death
spiral according to experts as the
quality of these services rapidly
declines people are looking into
alternatives which produces revenue for
the city from these services according
to article post in 2017 suggest that
over a five-year period passenger
revenue has expected to drop by 485
million dollars and as the city is
losing significant revenue from these
services it becomes even harder for them
to make improvements leading to a
catch-22 situation to make things even
worse
driving is not only a headache because
of traffic congestion but could also be
very dangerous 11% of the 162 bridges in
New York City are over 100 years old and
every day 2.7 million cars are for to
drive over bridges that are rated
fracture
which means exactly what the rating
suggests moreover it's not just
transportation as lacking either we see
the same problem with water and gas
lines there have been more than 400 main
water breaks in New York City every
single year except one since 1998 and as
for gas lines in 2015
experts concluded that there was at the
time over 1,000 leaky spots in New York
City and Manhattan
thanks to old pipe lines and natural gas
leak is three to five times as likely
compared to the average u.s. City on top
of all of this New York City has seen a
rapid increase in mentally ill people
living on the streets which has led to
many violent attacks on civilians
increasing fear among New Yorkers for
their own security as you can see over
the past few decades many things that
made New York City unique including job
opportunities and urban city life have
become available in many cities across
the u.s. this couple is a drastic
infrastructure deficit and the rise in
crime has made New York no longer
appealing for younger generations
especially given the costs have always
existed in New York specifically the
high cost of living in essence the pros
of New York no longer outweighs a con
for most people and even with
significant improvements to the city you
will not be able to become the icon that
a once was as identical services can be
found elsewhere and that's why people
are flooding from New York if you
thought this video explained the
downfall of New York City well then make
sure drop like also make sure to
subscribe if that's the more question
just like this one logically answered
but until then I'm hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]